here are this week's top movies how many  you got so far you and me riding into  theaters is the Magnificent Seven an  action-packed Western about a band of  gunmen hired to defend a poor village  seek righteousness but I'll take revenge  always deliver the family comedy stork's  follows the adorable adventures of two  friends on a very special delivery  one less baby to deliver can you do big  things from such a small place in the  inspiring Disney drama queen of Katwe a  Ugandan girl strives to become a world  chess champion she's sleeping  let's check out this week's Fanta  sebacean so what's your weekend ticket  going to be let us know by commenting  see you next time on weekend ticket